now to ethiopia where a civil war has
left tens of thousands dead and millions
displaced as government troops and the
tigran people's liberation front battle
over territory an investigation by the
united nations found all sides in the
conflict had committed violations
including using rape as a weapon of war
our reporter mariel muller went to the
amhara region to meet women recovering
from the trauma and here's a warning the
following report contains descriptions
of sexual violence
jeanette had no chance to run when four
men came to her garden
we are not identifying her in this
report
again
one of them put his feet on my shoulder
and burned me
while one of them burnt me with a
cigarette
another was forcing me to have sex with
him
the four men raped her for several hours
they left her with hiv and other
infections
and a deep fear
if they come back and take control of
the town again i have to die i'm very
scared
in this town hike during that raid last
november the men were fighters loyal to
the tigray people's liberation front or
tplf but men on both sides are using
sexual violence as a weapon of war
when janet asked the tigrans why they
were raping her
they told her government forces had done
the same in their towns to their mothers
and sisters
she's doing her best now to build a
future and has started a distance
learning course
she wants to set up a small business
i want to go to school because i didn't
attend a school as a child
now education is good for my work to get
more knowledge and live a better life
just a few streets away a 14 year old
girl she also wishes to remain anonymous
the the grain fighters came to her home
too
one of them said i will take one of you
and i'll kill one
my aunt begged him but he said no i will
kill you and take one of you
so i told him to leave them and do
whatever he wants to me
he didn't kill her he raped her for much
of the night
since then she often misses school
for medical appointments but also to
avoid gossip and bullying
i prefer not to go to school
the people i used to play with there
now when i greet them
they don't want to play with me
but like jeanette salam has plans she
intends to become a police officer or
soldier herself
and get her own form of justice
i wish i could find him and kill him i
want him to die by my hand
we've listened to several other women
with similar stories across amhara
region
they can tell the world what happened
women over the buddha in tigre have
suffered similar attacks
but the de facto ban on journalists
means their voices cannot yet be heard